eleven season veteran in the NBA
three-time NBA champion in current agent
now in the Association business and most
importantly he tapes his podcast with
Gerald Brown after Suzy and I do every
single one to see you BJ Armstrong oh
it's always a pleasure is great to see
you right after this and I get a chance
to see the best and then we come in and
try to follow that done we try we look
it's it's the the best acts need a
proper set up so it's good to see you
here what is it like seeing Currie light
up an arena like that and in your days I
haven't seen arenas lit up I just
mentioned you know the shrug that
happened the drives game of the 26th
anniversary six-year anniversary that
happened over the weekend no rich I was
at the game last night and you know
being a former player being a point
guard you have to shoot a little bit but
when I was watching the games that's
like last night I realized that Steph
Curry is perhaps the greatest shot maker
the game has seen the variety of how he
made shots whether it's off the dribble
transition coming off screens he's just
an incredible shot maker and to watch
him just watch him consistently display
the accuracy that he has game in and
game out in high-pressure situations
he's just a phenomenal shooter so you
know if if I saw a guy make seven or
eight threes and in my heyday I would be
like oh he's hot Steph Curry
consistently does this night in and
night out this is who he is and it's
been incredible to watch as he's making
this run over the last four years so you
know it's amazing
we did the math or coordinated producer
Don Bowie told me this moments before
you came out here the most threes you
shot in your career in a season was 253
threes in the 94 95 he play does that in
a week the most that Curry's taken in
his career in 15 16 warriors 886 threes
I'll do the math word that's 633 more
than incredible and and that's the game
is totally changed is that an influence
of ker do you think here what do you
think it's an influence of the game the
game is trying to find space you try to
find space for great players to operate
and Steph Curry real
he made a step in the game to really
change the game he he just kept moving
out to create space and I think that was
kind of the the lead if you will a small
ball because he created more space and
you know you look for space on the and
the interior you know you had a gar like
Michael Jordan for instance who was a
guard who went and played really on the
post and then you have a gar like Steph
Curry who just started at the
three-point line and kept going further
and further back which really created an
opportunity for the other team to say
the only way we can defend him is to get
smaller players out there that can
defend farther away from the from the
basket so Steph Curry has really changed
the game if you will because he keeps me
though he keeps moving further and
further back which creates space on the
floor he created this space now that you
have that you just didn't see 15 to 20
years ago well I mean so then you're you
have unique perspective here again being
an agent for draymond Green JaVale McGee
Wasserman the Wasserman group that yes
the EVP for and managing executive the
Media Group also represents clay so that
yes that's three of the five starters
yes and you played with Steve Kerr so
what is kurz influence what is the
influence of maybe his playing days or
Phil Jackson's and I mean I'm trying to
put all these pieces together for the
latest dynasty that we're seeing forming
and oh right right now well I think
Steve Kerr what he brings is one he's
incredibly organized and how he sees the
game and he's not trying to be
when I played he's actually you know
when we talked and I talked to Steve he
actually has a sense of this generation
of player he can communicate I think
that is his strength his ability to
communicate with this generation of
player what Steve has done is allowed
these players and encouraged these
players to be who they are
draymond Green he encouraged dream on to
be draymond Green he encouraged Steph
Curry he encourages Klay what he did for
a JaVale to keep JaVale interested and
engaged so that maybe he wasn't playing
in the last series as much and all of a
sudden in game 2 he starts and he comes
up when he plays big so I think Steve
Kerr's ability to communicate with this
generation of player has been nothing
short of remarkable and its ability to
organize and you can see the way his
team plays and they're figuring it out
there they've been
doing this for four years and anyone
who's play understands you know it's
hard to listen to the same voice for
four years especially when you go for
this length of time and Steve Kerr
somehow someway he's been able to figure
this out now there was a great article
or an interesting article in the
bleacher report just a couple weeks ago
Howard Beck wrote about dream on and
Steve Kerr's relationship and how it was
never really hunky-dory that there had
to be any at the moment in the locker
room in Oklahoma City but yes her and
dream on arguing with each other how did
that all come about from your
perspective BJ Ostrom well you know and
watching watching it listening to it and
obviously working with dream on so I
heard Dre mom's perspective and I heard
coach Curtis perspective and the theme
is Steve is a very very intense you know
he looks kind of laid back you would
never sense that I think him and REM are
more similar than they probably will let
on and it was just an opportunity for
them to see each other and see each
other for who they are they're both
incredibly and competitive second they
are stubborn both are very very stubborn
and I thought that situation when they
collided if you will or they had this
argument was it really for them as the
opportunity of how much each other they
want to win it all came down to wanting
to win and those two they they butted
heads there but at the same time I think
there was a respect factor saying why
are we doing this and they were only
doing it for the saint they wanted the
same thing which is they wanted to win
they wanted to win badly and both of
them are very stubborn but I think that
situation has allowed their relationship
to move on and really flourish here in
the future and I think they've come to
the they've come to realize that you
know what we're actually the same person
and I think they have a great
relationship now is draymond Green and
occasionally needing to be cooled down
in the business world the business side
of things in the same way that you see
the coach needing to have him pump his
brakes for this competitive I think rich
what if you calm draymond Green down I
don't think he's draymond Green you have
to allow him to be who he is and that is
who that is the one who was always
pushing pushing the envelope he's all
right there on the edge you know
draymond Green you know physically he
isn't the biggest man he isn't the
strongest but he's a very strong player
but he isn't the strongest person on the
floor what he is is his basketball IQ is
off the charts he's like a basketball
savant
he knows not only his position he knows
what's going on on the entire floor he
is perhaps one of the smartest players
I've ever been around I don't care what
generation when you talk basketball with
draymond Green you better know what
you're talking about because he knows
the plays he knows the referees he knows
the coaches he knows everything that's
going on on the floor and when you
talked to him about basketball he can go
on and on and on and on he's just he's
just he loves the game but she doesn't
know sometimes where the line is I think
he knows I think yes dream on knows it's
not out of control he's not out of
control draymond is not out of control
this is he understands he's looking for
every advantage he can get on the floor
back in our day you know there was a
thing with the Pistons where you know
players would actually go out there and
you would try to intimidate players
there was gamesmanship within the game
Mahorn lambier that's a horn lam beer
Isiah Thomas
draymond Green grew up in that era he's
from he's from Saginaw he understands
that and I think you don't see that as
much in with today's youth as you did in
our generation but draymond is a
throwback he could play for the best he
could play for the bad boys he could
have played for those old New York
Knicks teams he could have played in
that era because Draiman always has
gamesmanship going on intimidation was a
part of our era this is what draymond
brings to this era you don't see it as
much but absolutely 100% he knows
exactly what he's doing I want to take a
60 second break and when we come back
with you BG Armstrong I wanted to throw
back the clock a little bit the
conversation of Jordan yes and LeBron
has just it's dominated and and I'd love
to get your two cents on that subject as
well as interpret the body language that
we saw from LeBron James on Thursday
night and video that just surfaced this
morning I'd love to get that Armstrong
right here on the Rich Eisen show when
you are back in 60 seconds
[Music]
game for the Stanley Cup Finals is
tonight we'll discuss that Peter Gammons
will join us in the baseball world the
Yankees in ESPN appear to be butting
heads will hit that there are ridiculous
story there are no fewer than four
mandatory minicamp snowing down in the
National Football League including the
one in New England Brady and Gronk their
status that is upcoming but for the
moment I turn to my right and I see BJ
Armstrong here for another segment on
the Rich Eisen show 11 seasons in the
NBA seven of them with the Chicago Bulls
winning all those championships and
being around Michael Jordan your
thoughts on this comparison of Jordan
versus LeBron James would be what BJ
Armstrong well I can see from a fan
perspective the comparison right they're
both wing players you know LeBron is
about six eight Jordan's about six six
and they both been the most dominant
players in their era but when I look at
it I look at it from the detail as a
player as an ex player they're two
totally different players LeBron is a
facilitator LeBron initiates LeBron will
do things that I don't think Jordan was
asked to do but more importantly I don't
think he had to do it you know LeBron
will initiate the offense he'll score a
little bit he'll rebound a little bit
he'll do all the things within the team
Michael Jordan was a scorer first second
and third he was a phenomenal phenomenal
finisher of the game and what I mean by
that is Michael Jordan stopped playing
the game he stopped having to facilitate
he didn't have to do all those things he
just finished the game he finished it he
was I think the game's greatest finisher
because he had no weakness in his game
when he played the game especially in
the fourth quarter we know we refer to
him as a three dimensional player he's
either gonna score he's going to get
fouled or he was gonna have or go to the
free-throw line and make the two
free-throws and not many players can do
that in the last four minutes of a game
Jordan was the best he was just three
dimensional in every way every phase of
the game especially coming down the
stretch I think LeBron in this year's
playoff run I thought he has done
better job than he has in years past had
been a finisher well the answer to that
would be as he has to because he because
you know Pippin is a top 50 players of
all time you know other than Dwyane Wade
in his entire career who else has he had
in that regard I know Bosh you know the
way the game the way the game is played
you know the the game is just a
different game today I would have loved
to have seen LeBron play in our era but
I would also love to see Jordan playing
this year because Jordan wasn't a
3-point shooter Jordan wasn't a shooter
per se he was a scorer so it would be
fun to really see how they would play
the different styles that you know if I
put Jordan in this era no hand checking
I mean the guy averaged 37 points a
night with hand checking what would that
translate into today's game where
there's where you can't touch him and
but then I would love to see LeBron with
this physicality that he has cuz he's
physically I mean he's just an imposing
figure I would love to have seen him
play against those physical and have
somebody with an armbar I would have
loved to seen how he would have played
against the Charles oakley's and the
Rick Mahorn 's and the buck Williams and
the physicality of the game so it would
been fun to play but without question I
want to say this about both LeBron James
is this generation is the best player
and I think Jordan was clearly that
generations best player now who's the
best
I think I'm biased I would say Michael
Jordan just because mentally what he was
able to do and I knew him Michael Jordan
is not going to back away from any level
of competition or any you know player
that comes up I think LeBron James would
meet the challenge because he he will
pose some problems for a player like a
Jordan any player because he's 6-8 to 60
but I would love to seen the matchup but
I'm gonna say Michael Jordan without
question BJ Armstrong here on the Rich
Eisen show
III have to have you tell the story you
told me ensues when you stopped on our
podcast about playing with Jordan and
he's it really true he never knew what
the score the game was I mean was that
really the case BJ well I think he knew
what the score was but he made a
conscious effort to always treat the
game as if the game was always 0-0 he
was such a unique perspective because
Michael Jordan always wanted to play
that possession and he was trapped like
in that moment and that's what I learned
about him he never you know when you get
up 20 there's a natural tendency to have
a letdown there's a natural tendency to
maybe back away Michael Jordan was
always zero zero always if you ask him
today what the score of the game is he's
gonna always approach it at zero zero
which kept him in that moment he never
let down he constantly kept the pressure
on you offensively defensively mentally
emotionally including in the huddle
including in the Huddle's and if you
asked him what was the score it was zero
zero and that to me was a different way
to approach the game and there were so
many things that were different about
the way he approached the game in the
way I or many of the other players in
the NBA I mean who goes out and you're
up 20 and you're still playing a game if
the score was tied but he did that he he
to practice that way he that was his
approach to practice that was an
approach to the game and if you ask him
ask him rich when you see him he's gonna
further without question say it's zero
zero but he would also bait young
players and to ask the young guys we had
a thing in Chicago called silly fires
and if we were up big especially in the
game we would ask the younger players to
rookie say what's the what's the score
of the game and of course of working
with look up and he'd tell the score of
the game and that was a silly fine so he
wanted to make sure that everyone else
was engaged into the game as well but it
was kind of our theme now where the
silly finds going to it when it's were
it was our it was our fun fun of money
that we all had
we all had a bear in case there was
something going on in a team and we
would we would shoot for something going
on like you know and it was we would
like to you know better about who's
gonna make the most free throws during
practice or who's gonna make shots or
who's gonna do things so it was our
little fund of money that we like to
play little kiddy money that we always
had good BG Armstrong here on the Rich
Eisen show speaking of not knowing the
score jr. Smith not knowing the score at
the end of that game have you ever seen
a situation like that before playing
college playing pro
agent in Pearl have you ever seen
anything like at the end of game one
before I've seen that before in that
particular setting at that time in place
I haven't seen it I mean that's one of
the biggest moments right for it to have
a he just had a mental lapse to say the
least
very unfortunate very devastating play
for the Cleveland Cavaliers I mean
there's no way to get around it for him
not to be aware of the timing score in
particularly at that specific time of
the game that's unacceptable for veteran
and I think you saw the bronze reaction
I think you saw the players around the
reaction to coaches to not be aware of
the timer score at that time I don't
know what really to say and I don't
think there's anything for him to say
other than you know what I just had a
mental lapse and you move on well I mean
in the first blush moments of trying to
move on there's now video as we've seen
this morning right and when you say well
there's nothing to say they literally
were not talking to each other right and
I know if tyloo's decide all right I'm
going to strategize and let them hash it
out and then come on in whatever
coaching philosophy that was or whatever
but when you see LeBrons reaction to
finding out that there was still a
timeout remaining what's your reaction
to seeing that video
BJ well you you never take these
opportunities for granted and it's one
thing about LeBron James I've come to
respect over the years he's very aware
of what's going on not only in his
particular situation but he's aware of
everything that's going on around him
LeBron James knows what this Golden
State Warriors team Game one was very
very important because Game one is kind
of the fill out game he went for it and
I give him credit for that
he was going for the win in Game one to
set the stage for the entire series I
mean he came out but what's going
through those temples when he put his
head and they when he put it I I think
he was devastated I think that was his
moment of like that was our chance and
we blew our chance to win that game and
possibly that series I don't think
there's any way to go around and I mean
you don't
put your hands in your head during the
NBA Finals during the game especially
when you know you have over time to play
the game I think that was just a moment
that they had where they had a chance to
win it I mean you have a chance to win
Game one on the road in the finals
versus the Golden State Warriors you
don't let that opportunity slip by if
you miss the shot so be it but to have a
mental lapse like that I think was just
devastating and you saw how they
performed in overtime I think they just
they didn't move on they didn't turn the
page I think they were stuck there and I
think it took them a couple of days I
thought you know in Game two they
rebound it but to lose that opportunity
I think is just because you never know
when you're gonna get that chance back
and to lose the game that way it just
just took the air out them as you will
so I before we take one more break in
and have you finished the our this and
if you're on hold please stay on ole and
take all your calls at the top of the
next hour I'm gonna spin the
conversation forward because I know it's
it they probably even having this
conversation on the split screen hashtag
bark fests on some other networks
another radio shows that LeBron should
have snapped out of it he's the leader
of the team he's the guy he should have
been the one run in the huddle he's the
de-facto coach anywhere that everybody
thinks series he should not have been
lost in that moment as crazy bat guano
insane as it really was that he should
have snapped out of it and let everybody
tell him it could have been a different
result how do you respond to what I'm
sure is going to be out there if not
already well when you're playing you're
emotionally involved in the game you're
in the year you have everything you have
in that moment LeBron James it's hard as
a player in that moment to just really
separate the emotion of what's going on
at the time I mean he's trying to look
at the game time and score he was
looking at the the situation and all of
a sudden he was emotionally like what is
going on it was kind of like no one knew
what was gonna if you look at the tape
the defense didn't know what was going
on no one knew what was going on other
than junior junior was the only one
that's kind of and you could
he didn't know so everyone was kind of
like there was a moment of confusion I'm
with you yeah human being he's a human
being
what why you know I know everyone's
gonna be the why didn't I call the time
out and even LeBrons reaction was
there's yet a time beyond the
three-point arc there was one second
left now obviously can make a play but
all right I want to take a break come
back and just get a couple more cents
about the future for LeBron and the
Warriors best you can tell from your
agent Dean pointed yes Vijay Armstrong
here at BG Armstrong on Twitter you're
on hold please stay on hold here on the
Rich Eisen show all right one more
second with BJ Armstrong in the key with
BG Armstrong and Gerald Brown on podcast
one every single week enjoy and doing
the podcast love it rich it's something
that you never know what to expect but
it's something that's been great it's
been a great way to engage more
importantly to be able to you know
engage with the clients people like
yourselves and people in the business so
I'm really having a lot of fun doing it
yeah you've had you've had Oakley
Desmond Howard Horace Grant on man
that's great Rich Eisen you've had me on
yes
who came on the one with me and Sue's it
was a nice little home at home that was
fun
what do you think's gonna happen with
LeBron you're an agent what do you think
July 1 hits what do you think well the
one thing I've come to realize as an
agent nothing is going to happen until
LeBron James makes a decision so LeBron
is gonna hold up free agency you know
every year we get excited and then when
LeBron is in free agency nothing's gonna
happen day 1 day 2 day 3 now once he
makes a decision then the dominoes will
fall so what I think he's going to do I
think he's going to take his time with
it and I think he's gonna look at a
couple of places right whether that's
coming out on the west coast you know
there's been a lot of speculation about
Los Angeles or all these different
places but I think he's gonna take his
time to see where can he beat the
Warriors because if you come on the west
coast
what's your can you put together a team
that can actually beat them I don't
think so but I think staying in the East
will give
the best chance to prepare to beat the
Warriors because if the Warriors are
able to stick together I mean they're
young enough to where they're gonna be
around for the next three or four years
now in the two minutes that have left
I mean Wasserman and the whole group
there can got three of the starters I
mean the disease of Moore's you know a
always talked about that that's right
yes disease of more Klay Thompson's
already said essentially like hey I live
out on the coast I've you know I'm
winning championships um I'm a happy guy
draymond Green is he a guy that's gonna
want to get paid and and I think the
Warriors will have to make obviously
some business decisions without question
now what those decisions are going to be
who knows but the decisions are going to
have to be made and Pat Rowley I think
he nailed it the does you know the
disease of more you know we called in a
Chicago the me factor the me factor is
going to come in and everyone is going
on at some point want to you know be pay
for their worth or what their perceived
worth maybe their perceived worth
whatever they feel it is so I think that
will come into play when I say come into
play contracts and all those things the
business of basketball the business of
sport will come into play I do think the
Warriors will figure it out because the
Warriors have a unique situation where
all those players were drafted with the
exception of Kevin Durant so I think
they can figure it out but you know what
it's one of those problems I would love
to have if I was an owner because
they've been to the finals with the
possibility and the potential to win
three out of the four so I think it's
one that will figure itself out as they
move forwards is something you talk
about with dream on like hey you got a
good spot I do not um I think it's
because I'm superstitious as a player I
never talk as an ex player so I never
like to talk about the financial part of
it with players especially during the
season at the at the right time we will
have a conversation about it but this
isn't the time now right now is for him
to focus in on what he's doing what he
needs to be doing which is focusing in
on this moment in time I mean to be here
with an opportunity to win three out of
the four three championships in four
years that's not something that you do
every day it's rare at BG Armstrong on
Twitter
in the key with BJ Armstrong and Gerald
Brown on podcast one I love having you
here let's do it Ritz thank you I
appreciate the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience